I've always been very good at training
you know and that was part of why I quit
the first time because I could train I
know like the best in the world and I
know now because I'm still training with
those guys but I could never race like
that you know I didn't figure out the
sport you know I just didn't know how to
apply that trending to train just
because you like training I love
training I love exercising I mean I call
myself a professional exerciser but it's
funny like even when I was rowing and
we'd get on the bike like if you could
do 400 watts for like 20 minutes at you
know 70 kilos 150 pounds that was pretty
a pretty solid effort I said well mate
22 years later it still is
that feeling has not changed and I said
I can't even believe I'm still doing it
but uh I am and I and you know and I and
I apply myself the same way I did 22
years ago right you know I I just love
it I love
I love exercising